um you know the different i guess
tactics going into it and of course uh
one of the the other things that we're
seeing is is so much more representation
from around the world and you know the
different regions that we're
highlighting anyways it looks like it's
going to be a matchup between kunimitsu
and king that's who umitsu
another character that a lot of people
kind of have been talking about lately
um due to her efficiency
yeah i mean you know when a player is
named unga bunga i like seeing that
their character choice is kuni mitsu
because this character can definitely
get unga bunga oh yeah exactly how he
decides to play i think this character
can be played very safe or he can play
very own gabon but uh we're going to see
what he decides here x-star we saw very
oh my gosh
yeah x-fire has been the star of the
losers bracket so far from what we've
seen you know he's obviously made his
advance here oh my gosh right now he's
playing he's going in
that uh from crouch down forward to he
made a count
all right there he goes he went for a
toe kick there interesting
xr taking that first round as we go into
let's see what unga bunga is able to do
here is it is it like um or is it like
controlled um that's what i want to know
yeah right now it's looking controlled
to me
yeah maybe a little bit to control
because x-star is is able to land a lot
of these hits so far oh my gosh
okay the bunga might be coming
one way to do it is with lowe's oh he
went for the power crush but he got
shining wizard for oh my god he's he if
that hits the wall he's done it might be
short of the wall
exploder
oh that was a stick he charged oh my
gosh all right hit him on his cover hit
him hit him you want oh my god he's
wasting speed are you wasting my
sparkles
hella wasted the sparkles
oh oh nice nice option that that hits
around 50 oh boy all right good choice
there
x-star staying composed here i feel like
we need to normalize key charging as an
as an attack a pressure move
oh yeah there are so many there's so
many crazy setups that you can do
uh-huh here we go
so many low counter hit launchers that a
lot of characters oh my gosh the spring
kick
it starts come back oh nice one setting
three here we go yeah that was the face
down feet away into the while standing
attack there from mungabolga
khadex start off guard something to look
back later
i do i've never seen that option that's
crazy
yeah you get like 442 guaranteed i'm
pretty sure it's guaranteed yeah oh here
we go shoulder
into the swing again yo x-star if i'm
x-star i'm doing giant swing all the
time now because he's uh not broken him
too far one plus two shiny wizard will
give x-star the game
nice to done x-star chilling big
chilling right there uncle bunker really
didn't get started right the round three
look kind of good uh but the rest of it
really not working out
are you sending a character switch
no
no i mean stick to kudimitsu
well i i i don't know honestly
let me let me think i have to do this by
feel just because i'm not familiar with
the characters or the players yeah so
let me say let me think
this is going to be a good test of my
feels
he's going to stick to
he's thinking feeling he's going to
switch
okay we'll see we'll see how this goes
the reason i say that is because
cootie's a relatively new character
right so
he was playing something else in tekken
7 beforehand and the kuni got kind of
smoked there so bring out the bunga with
the other character that's what i'm
saying
okay i mean that's it that what other
character do you think
this is a huge guess because there's you
know a lot of characters if it's
that would be so funny let's let's bet
on character let's bet on character come
on what do you think i think it's
yoshimitsu
okay i think it's marduk
wow
wow okay all right i think that if
you're a cootie mitchu player you
probably are from the mitsu line you
know like you probably comfortable okay
okay
all right all right yeah
right otherwise it could be something
like real i'll tell you one thing i am
sure of x-star cannot change his
character i'll say that yes i think
we're in agreement on that point x-star
gonna be sticking out king definitely
been our hero with the loser bracket so
far and he's he's really the younger
bunga too right like i mentioned earlier
you know if this man is if you can knock
him down he's tech rolling some kind of
two button attack is coming your way
it's gonna be wild and two two gut funds
too you know like something's coming so
you gotta be careful
but right now it's looking good for him
you know up one game here moving on
could be the top five if you can get
past unga bunga
yeah of course we have one other match
here in the losers bracket
uh before we get uh back into the swing
of things man we're gonna see some of
the players that we got knocked out of
the winner's side earlier that you just
saw and again there were some great
matches man that first match with calum
and big daddy mike that one was crazy
went down to the very very end
yeah i wish we had started the stream
with that they would we'd have been out
of energy by now you know uh yeah but
gotta conserve i mean it's early for us
i don't know if you're like awake yet
but i'm definitely awake after seeing a
lot of these matches so it's good stuff
i'm shocked you know i didn't realize so
much time with god we've been here
almost two hours already right it's uh
it's 5 40 a.m out here on the west coast
of the united states so it's it's quite
early for us uh but we've had some great
match so far you know and still more to
come i'm sure right now i think we got
uh we're tied up we're one zero right
now right
so
we'll see
if we can see anything crazy out on the
bunk i hope we do i hope we get a
character switch
is it
no i told you i told you damn you're so
good at this
i really thought it was gonna be a
switch i was like very confident that's
why i asked you i was like he's gonna
switch for sure right he started the he
started playing kuni mitsu
and only kuni mitsu now i'm playing i
don't know
he just got a tekken 7. he's heard about
tekken he's like what's this i like this
kuni character i'm gonna pick that up
make top eight of my first tournament
ever
all right here we go mishima dojo
see how this plays out here nice goes
for the sobato this time see the one
thing i want to see from
he needs to force the interaction more
he needs to like do things he he got
that big low you know early on with that
from crouch on four three he needs to
put the mix on even size to four right
he landed the size of four didn't take
the guaranteed four four two after it
either so he's not taking the guaranteed
442s in situations he could have it and
he's not really going for them as much
key charge again with no health left and
you can see this is a bad idea because
it's gonna be like an up for three or
something something relatively safe for
next star he's not scared of that key
charge
and xr is not afraid of ducking he's
been ducking a lot of the stuff that
ungoboon has been doing as well i don't
know if uh
okay he didn't duck that time this time
going for the ford ford too
nice power at the wall has been working
out for him right when he's done a
little further away it's been a little
bit scarier but right at the wall it's
working oh it doesn't matter
okay okay let's get the back
pouch again yeah this is gonna hurt
this is maybe where he turns things
around let's see what he does ollie oh
my gosh
oh don't just hit the brakes a little
bit
wow he could have killed him right okay
he got him he got him all right all
right uncle bunga time go
fight
this is a great name it's like my
favorite name so far from all the
players
this is definitely one of the coolest
names i told you check for whole walt
dan two two hop kick
what's he do that was dick damn
oh the follow up here he gets the combo
the bunga it's coming he's getting
longer
what the hell we try to do some crazy
stuff
he might turn on there i don't know
hey the blue stuff oh
the mid and the running oh man all right
all right
trouble right now for unga bunga x-star
looking to advance
yeah trouble in paradise to see x-star
will he be oh that's a big block that's
a huge block he's gonna get the wall as
well
but what what's the option he goes to
the ground throw
oh my gosh it might be over rip it might
be over oh it's over we're rolling it is
over owen
the under the bunga
damn see you later x-star moving on in
the bracket rolling death cradle very
nice yeah he did his